speaking of how crazy in the next four
years is going to be Donald Trump um
this weekend before before the holiday
even could even get kicked off in
earnest Donald Trump decides to tweet
out that America actually let me read
his words exactly the United States must
greatly strengthen and expand its
nuclear capability until such time as
the world comes to his senses regarding
nukes okay Pat um this is so the tweet
is it should we even try to analyze it
as Donald Trump but here's the thing
saying that until the world becomes
comes to a census on nukes while
starting the tweet saying we need to
expand our nuclear capacity is enough
ammunition no pun intended for the rest
of the world to never come to their
senses on nukes like if you say hey we
are going to build our nuclear capacity
than every nuclear state is going to
build their capacity further and
non-nuclear states are going to see okay
well this is the world we live in we
need to build so this tweet itself is
undermining any sense any common sense
with regard to nukes yeah I think since
the end of the Cold War we have come to
our senses regarding nuclear weapons and
how powerful they can be exactly and so
with um with this story you would I
don't know if anyone's watching anyone
puts themselves themselves through this
and watches Morning Joe but Mika
Brzezinski mentioned in on Morning Joe
on Friday morning that in her
conversations with Donald Trump he said
if there's an arms race let there be an
arms race and we'll i'll spend them and
we'll win so two things 1i think Donald
Trump really believes is right too I
think he does not care that it
undermines his very intention of the
world coming to his senses on tweets but
number three this is more of an anything
else this is a signal to defense
contractors particularly nuclear
contractors that we're getting ready to
spend a whole lot of money and this is
going to be Christmas for them for the
next four years he's also just entirely
ignorant when it comes to the issue of
their weapons except you remember during
one of the Republican debates uh that
right try try it Brady 52 submarines and
the missiles right you know in the
context of them being very outdated and
he just went on this rambling world word
salad kind of response to it right so he
is completely uninformed um and poorly
misinformed like he's both right he
really buys way way that's a whole
different story that's because in his
briefings that he's gotten he keeps
bringing up the issue of nuclear weapons
and asks why can't we use them right
that mean that was the other story from
earlier this year particularly uh it's
like Morning Joe gets all of these off
the record scoops with uh with Donald
Trump and I use scoops really loosely
but that was what Joe Scarborough said
earlier this year with regard to Donald
Trump the nuclear weapons he asked over
and over again why can't we use them and
so you know III don't know here's my
problem I have a lot of people and I
hang out with a lot of people in the far
left right I'm pretty far love and I see
a lot of people in the far left who
dismissed this story as nonsense as
though there's not really something we
should worry about Donald Trump is not
going to be that in basilic and stop you
know fear mongering trying to you know
this is this weird intersection between
the rejection of the Democratic status
quo which the Democratic status quo was
absolutely running to the heels with
this one right there they're they're
taking Donald Trump to the woodshed with
this so you have the far left which I'm
a proud member of who looks at this and
says oh well it's not really a scary
story you know don't try to make it out
to be that bad but I'm like these are
words coming out of the mouth of the
president-elect of the United States
like everything he says now is one
hundred percent newsworthy as well as
something we should take seriously it's
like he's trivializing the issue of
nuclear weapons as if it's some sort of
bargaining chip for him he's coming off
of these so-called victories when it
comes to the fore deal in the carrier
deal and I think he's just trying to
leverage Putin in a certain way and gets
what he wants in a sense to right and so
in this case it's not just right you're
absolutely right there it's not just
Putin it's every nuclear armed nation
that listens to this and says okay we're
going to start spending again
granted we spent we waste more we waste
more defenseman defense contracts then
most nations combined put in tort so
they can't outspend us he's right in
that regard but that makes us that much
more unstable because now people who are
they feel like they're in a weaker
position it's like a caged animal right
you you back an animal into a corner
they're going to lash out violently so
this type of language itself this is
what I think I want to convey the most
is this language the tweet itself is a
dangerous thing because of what it
signals to the international community
and we also have enough nuclear weapons
on the planet to blow the world over 20
times f is enough don't be spending all
this money it states going down the
drain it's going down the drain and so I
had this the last thing I'll say on this
one because this one kind of it bothers
me more from the critical analysis of my
friends on the left here's the thing if
you thought Hillary Clinton's no-fly
zone was going to lead to a nuclear war
with Russia which was a prevailing
theory during the election how could you
not be concerned about a guy who says we
want to double down on arms race on the
Cold War spending money on nuclear
weapons is like it doesn't something's
not connecting there for me maybe
because there's been so much criticism
of him being buddy-buddy with Putin as
in recently he's trying to play the
other end to it too I mean that's one
theory I may have I mean but that would
be a safe theory if the only other
nuclear power in the world was Russia
but they do have the biggest stockpile
of nuclear weapons yeah but only enough
I mean it only takes one or two they
said everything in motion all right so
anyway that's Donald Trump this is ben
this has been our car holidays Christmas
Kwanzaa whatever you call it this has
been our weekend with our incoming
president elect today's program is made
possible by blue apron blue apron sends
you pre-portioned ingredients and
instructions to cook meals in your own
home I love blue apron I'll tell you a
little bit about the recent recipe that
I cooked they also have partnerships
with over a hundred and fifty local
farms and Fisheries and ranchers across
the u.s. and blue apron can be delivered
to 99 percent of the continental US
99.5 percent of food deserts and you
know I hate waste and hate wasting food
blue apron will ship you the exact
amount of each ingredient that's
required for a recipe so you never waste
anything and if you spend a lot of money
eating out or at a high-end grocery
chain you can now spend under 10 bucks
per person for really really great meals
some of the meals available this month
include the Thai green coconut curry
with sweet potato and jasmine rice I
made this actually the other day the one
thing that I always find funny with the
blue apron recipes is they allow you to
decide how spicy you make it so for
example with the Thai green coconut
curry of dish it came with a container
of green curry and it says use the
amount you want based on your spice
tolerance and my normal thing is I just
put the entire thing in and it was
actually pretty spicy not uncomfortably
so but about the maximum amount of spice
that I would want and it was really
really great also available in December
the brown butter and chestnut yoki with
brussel sprouts and pea shoot salad
check out this week's menu get your
first 3 meals for free with free
shipping at blue apron dot-com / Pakman
that is blue apron com / PA ke ma n blue
apron is a better way to cook